you made this documentary clearly very
near and dear to your heart the Zen
diaries of Garry Shandling and you were
very close with Gary and Garret was a
big mentor to you and met Gary was a
mentor to a lot of us a lot of us who
came up in comedy in this generation
idolized Gary Shandling and I found out
so much about him watching this
documentary and it's interesting
experience because it's a beautiful
documentary it's fantastic and then at
the same time it makes me miss him all
over again
yeah in this way that so you know screw
you
it hurts to have feeling it hurts to
have feelings yes so I'm not doing that
again
no mores feelings but I learned so much
there was something that I I knew this
but I think it's gonna really shock
people because Gary was a very spiritual
guy Gary it had a near-death experience
very early in his career as a stand-up
and it changed the whole trajectory of
the way he looked at life yeah he he was
writing episodes of shows like Three's
Company and Sanford and Son and Welcome
Back Kotter and he was doing stand-up at
night at the Comedy Store but hadn't
gotten good yet Mitzi shore kept telling
him you know you're just a writer you're
not a performer and she was being tough
on him and one day he he's driving his
car in the rain and a car hits him from
behind and so he gets out and he's
looking at the damage and he's in
between the cars in another car hits
that car from behind and crutches Gary
yeah in between the cars and he goes you
know to the hospital and he was very
proud of the joke he said as they
brought him into surgery which was just
a little off the back right and and he
says that during the surgery he he'd
floated above he heard everything he
said and then he saw the light and a
voice said do you want to continue
living Garry Shandling's life and he
said yes and then he used that to work
up the courage to be a stand-up comedian
and do all the things that he did get up
on stage and what he does next is really
remarkable he George Carlin of course
was idolized by you know still today by
so many people in comedy
but then he was the stand-up comedy
it would be him maybe Richard Pryor but
people just love George Carlin and he
did something that took a lot of guts he
decided I've got to go and see George
Carlin and see if I can give him some
jokes and this is a guy who had you know
really no business doing that well he
was I think 20 years old I just you know
he was twenty twenty-one finishing up
college he drives to see a George Carlin
show which is at that time just had a
little Club because he had just become
the hippie George Carlin and he wrote
him a bunch of jokes and George Carlin
said come back tomorrow and I'll tell
you what I think of him and he comes
back the next day they're laid out and
he had written all over it and he said
you know what there's a great joke on
every page so if you want to be in this
industry I think that you are talented
enough to do it yeah and then Garry just
moved to LA and took that as a sign that
he could make it and I think that's why
he mentored other people like me because
George Carlin was so kind it's amazing
when you see this documentary you see so
many people today that are huge stars
incredibly successful that Garry
personally made their career possible or
helped helped it alone
certainly which is amazing and you have
a weird experience where when you were
being considered for the the late-night
spot so was Gary yeah and you you guys
your lives really intertwined and then
after I got the late-night spot he
called he got on the phone with me and
talked to me and I just couldn't believe
it he couldn't have been a nicer guy it
was just such a gentleman yeah the whole
thing and and so funny I mean I was I
read through his journals he had 30
years of of journals and the estate
allowed me to read them because Gary was
considering putting out a book he was
gonna do something with his journals but
there'll be these really funny things
sometimes it would be very emotional and
other times he would just write jokes
but one thing that made me laugh was he
did this movie called what planet are
you from and he wrote it and it came out
terribly and he was he was very upset
about it just it was a misfire yeah and
so he he wrote a fake quotes for the
poster I I don't know if he ever showed
this or you did it for his own amusement
but he wrote I tried my darndest to pull
this off Garry Shandling
we all make mistakes that's the last
time I trust my instincts Gary I hate
myself Carrie I thought Mike Nichols
Garry Shandling Greg Kinnear Ben
Kingsley and that Bening what could go
wrong wait till you see the you worked
on the Larry Sanders Show and the Larry
Sanders Show I think really did create a
new kind of comedy this single-camera
comedy that now I think there's a whole
generation that only understands comedy
that way
that's the only way they can see comedy
so Gary was certainly you know at the
forefront of that you worked on that
show and when you watch this documentary
it's clear how how much of himself he
put into that show and how tortured he
was about it and you were there to
witness it yeah no it was pretty intense
because you know when you make a movie
they shoot about four pages a day
sometimes five on a big day for some
reason they would rehearse three days a
week and then shoot 17 pages a day and
so Gary was the head writer and he had
to act 17 pages a day so if he walked up
to him and said hey can you read next
week's script he's like what I can't do
that so he was really really exhausted
the whole time and so it was an
impossible situation
but he just powered through and made you
know one of the great TV shows of all
time yeah and but you can see how much
it took out of them yeah oh you watch
when you watch the the documentary we
have a clip here and I believe this is
where I did I love that you picked this
clip but it's just Gary being
interviewed yes
by I don't know who the newsman name is
Brian Lenihan and he's from Canada this
is just a funny interview Gary do not
remoting with this Warren Beatty movie
he was in and it just gives you a sense
of Gary yes thank you a sense of how
particular and unique his comedy vibe
was it was so distinct with siglo when
you say that acting is hard for me
because I'm still learning to feel
instead of verbalize that's right where
are you now well you know I think I'm
getting better at it I find myself
having to cover less with my comedy than
them I used to and I'm able to sort of
you know and that's why it's a challenge
for me that's why I wanted to ask
because I think I can grow as a person
through it maybe not you make me
uncomfortable I don't know why why do
you think I don't know I have a couple
of ideas
the Zen diaries of Garry Shandling is
really special and I would say it's I
also think it's an important documentary
for people to see it's about so much
it's not just about Gary it's a lot of
it's about how comedies made how people
try to make something funny and what it
takes out of them and there's a lot of
it's just about people trying to figure
out what life's all about and so I took
out so much from this from this
documentary that I think people will
love the two-part HBO documentary film
the Zen Diaries of Garry Shandling
debuts March 26th and 27th on HBO check
it out
Judd Apatow great work
[Applause]
you